from inside one of britain's most secure
jails a plea for help from its most
notorious prisoner a man who's been
locked up for nearly 50 years i'm 70
years old now martin
17 years old
i've never murdered anyone i've ever
raped anyone
what am i in jail for
people don't believe it they think i'm a
serial killer
the prisoners best known as charles
bronson but now calls himself charles
salvador
jailed originally for armed robbery in
1974 he's been kept in prison with only
two brief releases because of a series
of attacks on jail staff
bronson's solicitor says he's reformed
and is urging the justice secretary to
grant a pardon
in a letter to dominic raab he asks him
to use his prerogative to free bronson
because he says he's made great progress
in prison
he said in the letter the evidence in
excess of the last five years is clear
that his risk of violence has
significantly reduced
the argument is that if he's been able
to demonstrate that he's not violent
within very high risk
situations in custody towards staff
governors etc then the risk falls away
if he's released to the put into the
public because historically whilst there
was a risk to the public it's never been
as severe as towards prison staff and
governors
but you accept that there is still a
risk of him being violent if he were to
be released there is very good
psychological research evidence that as
someone ages the risk of violence
decreases
when someone approaches 70 the
research shows that that drops off to
zero
now he's at that age bracket
in 1999 bronson took a prison teacher
hostage for two days he got a life
sentence but was eligible for parole
three years later
he's soon to have another parole hearing
likely to be the first held in public
but his solicitor claims the ministry of
justice has done little to help him
prepare for it there's no independent
scrutiny he decisions are made on him by
people that don't know him
during one period of freedom in an
amateur boxing match bronson
demonstrated his physical fitness
something he says he's kept up
i can still do 95 press ups in 30
seconds so i'm still there
mate
bronson's parole hearing is not expected
until the end of the year
martin brunt sky news